- Let me show you,
why this Bangkok street
food stall is so famous.
Look at this food, it looks unbelievable,
and the portion sizes are huge.
It looks absolutely stunning.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Micah, is your mouth
watering for some crab?
I think it is.
Hey everyone,
it's Mark Wiens in Bangkok, Thailand.
We are on our way to go eat at this
awesome-looking street-food stall.
Ying, what's the name of the stall?
- Nhong Rim Klong.
- Aha.
- OK, that's the name.
This place has been getting very popular,
and has been really shared a
lot on social media, lately,
in Bangkok and in Thailand.
And, you will see that
the food looks awesome,
and so I'm very excited
to go check it out, today.
- [Ying] He looking at microphone, Mark.
- [Mark] He's looking at your what?
- [Ying] Microphone.
- [Mark] The microphone?
- [Ying] Yeah.
(playfully talks in foreign language)
(upbeat techno music)
- We made it to Ekkamai,
that wasn't too bad of a drive.
And, what soi is it on, Ying?
- [Ying] 21.
- 21.
OK, so we gotta go down
the street to Soi 21.
I'm not sure exactly where we'll park,
but we'll try to find a
parking, and then walk there.
We made it to Soi 21, and,
it's gonna be a very, much better idea
to take public transportation,
take a taxi here.
Parking was a bit of a mission impossible,
but we finally made it.
We made it to the
restaurant, Micah is here.
It is situated next to a canal,
which is not the cleanest
canal that I've ever seen.
And then they are cooking right there,
and they have a few tables set up,
and then I've also heard
that a lot of people
order takeaway.
They hire motorbike drivers to come here,
and wait in line to place their orders.
But luckily we got here pretty
early, it's about 10:45 a.m.
before the main lunch rush.
And Ying is,
let's zoom in on Ying.
She is right there,
putting in our order.
Even though there's not a
lot of people sitting here,
a lot of people pre-order,
and so they got a lot of orders to make.
But she is just flying on that wok,
you can here the wok
clanking, and actually,
this is just an awesome street-food stall.
It is literally, they are,
the restaurant and all
the cooking in the kitchen
is on top of a bridge that
goes across the canal.
And then, the sink is absolutely classic.
The sink just runs straight
into the canal, and,
along with the smell of the canal,
it's overpowered by the wonderful smell
of frying garlic and
chilies, and that crab,
and all the seafood that she's cooking.
They are known here especially
for their seafood dishes,
especially their crab, shell less crab,
and that is an entire
wok-full of shell less crab,
and she just added a bunch
of eggs, and so many, good.
If you just stand here, that aroma,
pouring out of the wok is just beautiful,
and she is an amazing chef.
She's even talking on the cellphone,
multitasking as she's cooking.
Some serious skills.
(chef talking on cellphone)
Micah's sleeping through
this entire experience.
Hello, Micah.
(Ying speaking in foreign language)
That was about a 45 minute
wait, but let me show you
why this Bangkok street-food
stall is so famous.
Look at this food, it looks unbelievable,
and the portion sizes are huge.
Even photos do not do justice,
how beautiful this food is here.
Normally, if Ying and I go to eat
at a street-food restaurant like this,
we can easily eat like 4 to 8 dishes,
between the two of us, so
we order 4 dishes here.
These are monstrous.
And just the ingredients that they use.
At the front over here,
this one is tom yum talay.
It's a mixture of seafood tom yum.
I love how they put on
just a whole handful of
just not even chopped cilantro,
just whole cilantro and
dried fried chilies,
which are just crushed on top.
That is looking wonderful.
Let me just go ahead and taste that broth.
Ying has been tasting the broth,
and she says it is awesome.
That is so sour,
it will almost make your eyes squint.
The depth of seafoody flavor
in there is awesome as well,
and you can taste the
dried chilies in there,
as well as a refreshing cilantro taste.
This is the smallest plate
of food we have here,
and this one is goong tod kratiem,
which is shrimp fried with garlic.
It is a little bit oily,
there's a little bit of a pool of oil,
but then it's just topped
with a bunch of crispy garlic,
and these are kinda curled up.
Let me pick up all of
these guys onto my rice.
You can smell that garlic.
What I like to do to take of the tails,
is kind of poke it with my fork,
and then go in with my
spoon at the very end there,
so that hopefully it releases.
Oh no, that didn't work at all.
OK, there we go. Slide that off.
That entire shrimp just
tasted like fried garlic.
And it's so meaty and a little bit oily,
but really, really fragrant.
Yeah, that shrimp is also like a,
it's very muscular indeed.
This is one of their
signature dishes here.
It's called 'kahla pli
pad napla lea neux pu',
and it's cabbage on the
bottom which she stir-fried,
and then there is some kind of
signature mixture of crab meat,
plus maybe egg, plus,
I'm not sure what else,
but this is just,
what a beautiful pile of food this is.
And, I think maybe get some of this crab,
with a piece of the cabbage.
And these are just
whole sheets of cabbage,
look at that.
I think you just gotta
go in for the whole bite.
That's like half-cooked scrambled eggs,
with little nuggets of
crab meat, mixed all in,
and then with crisp,
lightly wilted cabbage,
to give it a fresh crispness.
It's another spicy dish, or
a very really flavorful dish,
but it's so rich and so good.
Oh, that egg and crab.
And then the final dish that we ordered,
and this dish looks like
it's gonna be my favorite,
even from just looking at it,
is Pad Khi Mao Buu,
and 'pad khi mao' is a
pretty well-known Thai dish.
It translates to "drunken
stir-fried crab",
and there is just massive
ingredients in here.
You can see all of the crab meat,
there's basil in here,
there's Kaffir lime leaves,
there are egg plant, there are shallots,
maybe those are onions,
there's just chilies
mixed in this whole dish,
and it looks absolutely stunning.
Is there anything else
down here that I missed?
It's just a solid plate.
Oh, lots of slices of
grachai, which is finger root,
in here as well.
Put this on to my rice.
That's the ultimate dish.
Even like, literally before I even chewed,
before I even closed my mouth,
I could taste that sweet basil,
just overwhelming my mouth.
And then the grachai, that gingery flavor,
you've got the nuggets
of stringy, sweet crab,
and then you can also really taste
the Kaffir lime leaves in there,
giving it a citrusy flavor as well.
OK, moving back over to the Tom Yum,
I'm gonna mix it up.
Oh, there's fish in here.
Look at that nugget of fish.
That tom yum is stunning.
The restaurant is packed
now, all of the seating.
And I found that Micah,
she starts to get really restless
when you sit for too long, and this bag,
I have to stand up and eat, but perfect.
Look at the standing table
they have, perfectly.
This food is absolutely stunning.
I am absolutely stuffed right now,
and I think having Micah on my stomach,
reduces my stomach space
because he kind of,
presses against my stomach.
I've got a little bit left to finish,
and then we had to take the
fried shrimp with garlic
and a little bit of
that tom yum back home.
So Ying is getting takeaway, she's outside
packing it in a bag at the front there,
cos these portions are gigantic.
If you come here, I think it looks like,
you could easily have just one plate,
order one plate of food,
especially the pad khi mao was gigantic.
The other dishes were not as big,
but you could literally come
here, order pad khi mao,
and share between two people.
That was absolutely
sensational if you wanna have
some awesome street food
crab, giant portions,
and it's not a cheap street
food stall to eat at.
You do pay, I think it's
about 200 baht per plate,
which is five or $6, so it's not cheap,
but for the ingredients
and the amount of crab
that you're gonna eat, it is impressive.
This is an amazing street food stall.
But definitely get here early
because it's packed now,
and you have to wait in line.
If you come right at lunch time,
you gotta wait in line, maybe, they said,
they were saying 2 hours now to wait.
So that was a very
successful food journey,
thank you very much for
watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up, if you enjoyed it.
And, if you enjoyed this food, and also,
if you leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you.
And also, if you're
not already subscribed,
then make sure you click Subscribe now,
for lots more food and travel videos,
and I will see you on the next video.
Good bye from Bangkok.
This will be my dinner tonight.
(upbeat instrumental music)